we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here's sort
of an unusual question that came in i'm
not even fully sure i understand it
let's take a listen to it and see if we
can figure it out
hi David I'm a first-time caller
longtime listener and I have a question
have you ever tried to go to Harvard
University or Stanford University and if
not did you ever try to go to a
community college alright thank you
so let's see I let's see if I can answer
it piece by piece I never applied to be
a student at Harvard University or
Stanford University I was not nearly a
good enough high school student to have
gotten into either of those institutions
I have gone to Harvard University
physically of course living in Boston
and having Harvard University just a
couple miles away in Cambridge
Massachusetts I've been to Harvard many
times I've gone to events at Harvard
I've gone to talks at Harvard I've never
been to Stanford now I don't know that I
understand the wording of if not did you
ever try to go to Community College I
don't know why it's Stanford or Harvard
or a community college but no I've also
never applied to or I guess it's more
like signed up for classes at Community
College I went to the University of
Massachusetts Amherst for my
undergraduate degree I went to Bentley
then it was Bentley College now it's
Bentley University here in the Boston
area for my master's degree so I what
did you make of this question Pat am I
missing something about the underlying
meaning of the question
the either/or thing I didn't really
understand isn't it also true that you
taught at a university like some college
was desperate enough to have you on as
an adjunct professor that's right and
that's exactly the framing that a lot of
people who email and said Boston College
was apparently so desperate for
professors that they brought me on to
teach a class a couple of semesters ago
yeah but all right anyway I hope I've
addressed the question in the spirit in
which it was asked we've got a great
bonus show for you today Chuck Norris a
new friend of Hungary's extremist
strongman leader we will talk about a
Christmas light displace
massive and so annoying that a town
wants homeowners to pay $75,000 is this
a tent attack on religious liberty we
will discuss on the bonus show and also
remember that false missile alert that
went out a man had a heart attack
as a result and he is now suing the
government over it all of those stories
and more on today's bonus show become a
member a WWJ pakman.com to get access to
the bonus show or become a patron for at
least five bucks a month both give you
instant access and I will speak to you
then